foreign
to me on the JK IG and I thought it'd be
fun to watch it together oh I haven't
even seen it but apparently a teacher at
a U.S High School quit in the middle of
class
I saw this oh you did no I didn't wow I
haven't seen it on Twitter's sweaters he
quit in the middle class she quit like
mid-class like I think she got fed up I
thought it was a he because you know
guys are weak
keep going
what happened yeah I'm gonna go I don't
even care if I don't get paid today I
don't care if I get paid today
I don't care I'm gonna do it anyway she
has a stereotypical old person's voice
I won't ever be back dang jeez I feel
bad that's pretty sad so I mean this is
why gen Z doesn't want to work because
if our role models don't want to work
yeah it's the teachers it's the teachers
it's the students I just want to know
what she did to make those kids yeah
and why did she make it about being an
old white lady yeah interesting she
calls herself stupid yeah that's
self-hate that's slow style that's
actually racism and if you talk about
yourself like that the kids will catch
on and they'll also call you stupid and
they'll start calling themselves stupid
old white ladies yeah yeah and it's
manifesting but honestly though teachers
you know I'm gonna say this and I'm just
not trying to get brownie points or
anything but teachers don't get paid
enough
[Music]
what a guy come on dude clap for me is a
little bit
can I just say that's not easy to say
yep and some say that those who can't do
will teach
oh
without the support of this room I don't
think I could have said a statement so
Brad you're safe here you're safe here
to say all this rap [__] dude so [__]
they don't get paid enough for this
[__] that's what I'm saying bro I
agree you could say this to a room of
people in like say the Academy Awards
and then get you standing up he'll give
me an award dedicated to my name yeah
will they start giving their millions of
dollars to the teachers union probably
not but they'll give you claps yeah
in honor for them yeah we should do
something about it yeah we're the most
powerful people on the Earth yeah do you
think every teacher you've ever had
deserves to be paid more no well
actually no I well I'll say it is
I think it's more of like obviously with
higher pay maybe it'll attract better
you know more quality I don't know if
it's the pay I think it's like they
can't get fired I think that's the issue
tenure I mean yeah well I do believe in
protecting you know uh the employee like
it sucks because if they're like if they
had a system of oh let's just pay these
younger guys cheaper right yeah I get
that that's Sinister but what do you do
on the flip side when people just got
tenure they got protection and they're
like I'm a coast now because there are
lazy teachers like that I've had so many
teachers that just don't give a [__]
about the students they're there they
just read straight from the book and
then they do the bare minimum dude it's
the thing that you hear all the time
it's like I get tenured next year it's
like I gotta just grind one more year
out like they say this [__] it's easy
yeah it's funny on both ends I think you
got you know people just milking the
system it's not like a good versus bad I
think whoever's milking the system
they're just [__] up the kids yeah
yeah 100 I think there is good and bad
there's teachers that really impact you
and have like a good
thing on your life and then there's
teachers that just should not be
teaching you always remember your great
teachers there's great teachers and then
there's teachers that mess kids who
impacted you
um
I forgot their name huh really they made
a mark
School teachers I mean my psychology
teacher was really really dope
um it just depends on the connection how
much they care about the kids
um I had teachers that cared about my
dance stuff and things I did outside of
it obviously my dance teachers which is
separate from like high school and stuff
had a huge impact on me yeah but and
then there's teachers that just suck
there are though I thought this one
teacher she was a math teacher I thought
she was a raging [__] [__] and I
always loved like making her class like
shitty I forgot what [__] happened
but there's some something happened
where she started treating me
differently and I just started feeling
like the help from her so I started
actually applying myself with math and
then at the end of the whole semester
like I was crushing it with grades and
whatever and she even wrote me a letter
and said like I'm so proud of you and if
you ever graduate and you want a job my
my husband owns a bank wow and you can
start yeah I could have been a [__]
Banker guy
oh my God you'd be [__] clear in
check yeah but I started going into
drugs and stuff so it didn't really work
out I think if you became a banker you
probably would have had like a Coke
problem
probably you probably would have
developed that now you don't have one at
all so what do you think the rate is for
like like percentage-wise like I would
say probably
30 of all the teachers I've had I would
say were good teachers very low yeah
it's not the majority I don't think it's
it's not for me it might be for maybe
some of you you're generally good a job
so I think it's probably 30 true that's
true most people aren't good at all jobs
yeah at all jobs yeah think about it
there's a certain personality to be a
teacher you have to give a [__] yeah
um even even if you're qualified for the
job to be able to teach somebody
um and for them to retain that
information in a way that's going to be
long lasting I think that is a special
skill in itself yeah because for
teaching you got to meet people where
they're at right and I think that's the
hard thing about a classroom is like
when you're teaching to a whole group of
people you have to kind of individualize
how you have your messaging towards a
certain subject especially how
complicated it is so then obviously when
you teach something one way half of the
room is not going to get it and there's
gonna be one kid who's like also you
know be a good student though too no 100
100 but at the same time but when
they're kids though like sometimes they
don't [__] it I mean yeah it's just part
of the part of this you have to
understand kids like if teachers had
more psychology and stuff and knew how
to work with kids some kids have
learning disabilities and stuff that
might not be super extreme but kids
struggle and they don't know how to
teach that tough because like a teacher
is going to have to gauge to the overall
percentage of the class not like the
select few who aren't keeping up I like
I think good teachers are like when they
give that mentorship and that guidance
and someone you feel like you can
connect to versus just teacher educator
teaching you knowledge yeah I think good
teachers teach and good students sit
down and say hey teacher teach me
something
hey when are you gonna teach something
this isn't going to make me a
millionaire
the funny thing is like when you go to a
school that's mostly Asian I feel like
classrooms majority of the students are
good students they come in with no
personality they just do their work and
you're just like okay that's all afraid
of their parents right right they're not
you could be a bad teacher and that kid
will still get an eight yeah because
he's just there to like do that thing
give me the info thinking of nothing
else and it's just surviving but when
you have like let's say a class where
kids are unruly and you're not a good
teacher that formulas that's when that
happens yeah exactly every single
[__] time and this this lady is a
substitute oh yeah so there's no respect
yeah yeah that's tough I've been to
something there's no [__] up classes
dude or like every single time when the
teacher turns around to like draw [__]
you just start chucking [__] at them or
like dude I remember this one math
teacher had a breakdown in the middle
class he was trying to do some [__]
algebra and then he turns around and
he's like
like watching the old man break down
that everyone was in tears crying
laughing and we just couldn't stop
saying I just want to teach dude we had
this one statistics teacher and he was
like a real sweetheart he was like a
real nice guy but then there'll be some
days where he's like oh okay I guess you
guys just don't want to learn today I
guess you know I just work so hard to
come up here and to teach you guys how
to do statistics but I guess you guys
don't want to listen it's fine just
close your books forget it no it's okay
I don't have to teach and he goes on
this whole tirade but it kind of does
work where everyone's like all right
dude just like sorry go go back to
teaching well shut up sorry and he would
do that every now and then like once a
once a semester or so and then everybody
be like when people get too unruly
Insurance you'll do that guilt trip oh
dude it's an impossible job I had a
great teacher in high school and I wish
I remembered his name but he was such a
cool teacher that people would skip
their class just to come to his class
and he'd let it happen because like his
teaching method was
um obviously teach the the formula but
then he would just incorporate just like
normal talk and just hang out with the
class and it was just like that balance
of learning something I think it was
social studies why are all the social
studies teachers cool is it his is that
history yeah
the humanities and [__] honestly
that's a good point yeah that's that's
probably why people get interested in
those like throwaway subjects because
the teachers were because my sociology
teacher was sick right right right right
because it's fascinating Concepts when
you're that age right because you're
like oh [__] this is cool I never
thought of it that way but that's how
you get into socialism and communism
because most of those guys are hardcore
leftists
not not execution Game Theory well and
then execution after the implement a lot
of executions guillotine
100 million or so majority of it it's
execution everyone in the Soviet Union
are just about like all the teachers
that I remember that were really good
were the ones that could explain complex
like like math math was always hard for
me and I think it was hard for most kids
because I think a lot of math teachers
they're really smart so and they
understand it so easily so it's harder
for them to like kind of dumb it yeah
simplify and dumb it down yeah
professors and teachers that could dumb
things down for a dummy like me I was
like oh this guy's way cooler but it's
because they have a better graphs of um
what they're talking about they have to
know you though yeah right that's true
no [__] hated math so much me too I
hated math but then I had a teacher that
actually paid attention to me and they
knew what I liked and they were like
okay Steve so like you like Smash and
puss awesome if you're some action four
[__] a day like you know in seven
days how much plus is that and I'm like
that's like 30 [__] something plus
and they're like and then she goes
that's a lot of puss nice it's 28 but
that's okay close like I was looking at
the upside you around I get it I think
it's breaking that wall that barrier and
make it relatable like you said like
understanding yeah yeah
it's like now okay if it's 28 vaginas
how many boobs is that and I'm like
almost 50. holy [__] [__]